Stakes of this counterpensive could not
be higher
this is not just a single military event
of course that consists of a lot of
elements including a psychological
warfare and Ukraine decided to
effectively impose a media lockdown to
keep everything very quiet I think they
want to retain this sense of surprise
the idea is to shatter the picture that
Vladimir Putin is trying to project that
everything is going according to plan
that there is a plan you really have to
sow the doubt in the minds of the
Russian soldiers and officers why are
they sitting in the stretches do they
want to die here and now in the war the
aims of which have never been really
formulated this is a war of narratives
as well as guns Western countries are
watching this very very carefully and
they will be making their decisions on
how to proceed on the basis of what can
be achieved in the next few weeks